on va passer au B du jour on va revenir
à l'agression très violente d'une petite
fille et de sa grand-mère en juin
dernier à Bordeaux la scène avait été
filmée la vidéo avait fait le tour des
réseaux à l'époque et ben ce weekend
l'agresseur a été condamné à 2 ans de
prison dont une de surcis pour
l'agression inadmissible les images nous
avaient tous choqué choqué ou pas choqué
par cette petite
peine
question alors bien entendu
comprenez-vous cette décision donc 2 ans
de prison dans teinte sur aussi pour
l'agresseur vous comprenez cette
décision c'est quand même incroyable
parce que le profil de l'agresseur 29
ans il s'appelle brima bald il avait
essayé d'entrer dans le domicile des
deux femmes une grand-mère de 73 ans et
sa petite fille de 7 ans la police
l'avait retrouvé quelques minutes plus
tard en caleçon de bain l'homme de 29
ans avait été placé en garde à vue puis
en hôpital psychiatrique face au juge
l'homme avait expliqué être intervenu
pensant que la fillette était en danger
se fout vraiment de la fillette estta en
danger c'est c'est flagrant bien sûr
c'est un sauveur non mais lui lui c'est
c'est un génie lui aussi tiens tiens
encore al lui c'est lui c'est un génie
apparemment il il était récidiviste hein
oui 15 condamnations délit routiers
stupéfiant d'accord donc lui c'est un
champion du monde lui là là franchement
ça ces images elles sont hor Gilles
c'est fou tu as énormément de courage
parce que toi tu comprends la décision 2
ans de prison dont un surc pour la
grasseur pour moi ça pour moi ça c'est
20 ans de prison pour moi ça pour moi ça
c'est 20 ans voilà moi je Mo voilà
moiuss bah non non on n pas d'accord ah
si surtout rcidiviste en plus c'est
unang publ mais là il pas si si si si
non non ah non non
non mais la problématique la peine va
être aménagée enance non non il il a été
déféré l'ISS à l'issue du procè il a été
déféré immédiatement il a été
immédiatement ce qui est un il a été il
a été déféré et placé en détension ce
qui est rarissime il faut le souligner
parce que pour une fois il va la il va
les faire c'est pour une FO le mec il va
bien se comporter en prison il va sortir
dans quelques semaines on sait très bien
comment ça se passe en France il y a une
problématique il y a la peine couru il y
a la peine prononcée et il y a la peine
exécutée le problème c'est au niveau de
la peine exécutée le mec va pas rester
un an en prison les juges le savaient
fondamentalement là c'est parce que
l'affire est médiatisé on l'envoie en
prison le mec va bien se comporter on
lui a décé un profil psychologique il va
sortir dans quelques semaines on a une
justice qui est instrumentalisée et
c'est scandaleux Gill non mais comment
comment tu peux être je vais vous
choquer mais moi je vais rendre je vais
rendre non mais je vais rendre hommage à
la justice là et et à la psychiatrie
parce que c'est un miracle qu'il soit
jugé Cyril la première expertise
psychotique schizop freine abolition
totale du discernement pas juger et il a
fallu que les juges shopstin qu'un
psychiatre dise pas du tout simplement
altération et il a été condamné et il va
faire de la prison normalement on dit
souvent ici vous savez les gens ils se
cachent et maintenant ils font tout pour
ne pas être jugés être déclaré
irresponsable lui il a tout fait il a
été jugé condamné pour violence
volontaire c'est terrible ce qu'il a
fait peut-être qu'il méritait plus mais
qui soit en prison c'est un miracle
judiciaire voilà donc pour moi je trouve
que cette décision elle n'est pas
choante elle est miraculeuse pour là où
a raison Gill c'est qu'on est passé de
l'abolition totale du discernement à
l'altération du discernement ce qui
permet de de le juger et donc et ça il
faut le mettre au crédit de des juges
qui ont qui ont bataillé pour réussir
à me soit libre dans quelques semaines
quelques mois ce mec qui a ruiné la vie
de la petite fille elle doit être
traumatisée à vie parce qu'il lui arrivé
pour les la grand-mère évidemment et
pour les autres potentieles victimes ce
mec là qui sont en liberté ce garsl ce
garsl je te le dis on veut qu'il
soitiminé de la
soci est d'accord mê pas ça vous êtes en
train de vous prendre la tête pour un
truc de 10 mois 8 mois 6 mois mais
regardez ce qu'il ce qu'il a fait
regardez ce qu'il a fait il a été
condamné 15 fois vous m'avez dit un
poison c'est un poison c'est un virus
c'est un poison il va nous empoisonner
la vie et ce qu'il essaie de faire là
moi ce que je vois là je vois déjà il a
faillli tuer la grand-mère parce qu'elle
il a faill lu fracturer une Crâ et je
vois un enlèvement d'une gamine je vois
un enlèvement d'une gamine c'est dire
dans 8 mois ou 6 mois ou 5 mois ne me
faites pas croire que ce mec là qui au
bout de sa vie qui qui a plus rien qui a
plus rien à jouer dans sa vie quand on
voit la degain ne me faites pas croire
que dans 6 mois il re kidnappe pas une
autre fille ne me faites pas croire ça
là on l'a juste laisser tranquille
pendant 6 mois on va lui donner à
bouffer en prison on va le nourrir on va
le laver on va l'habiller on va
s'occuper de ses dents et ses cheveux il
va ressortir tout beau tout neuf ne me
faites pas croire que dans sa tête il
enlève pas une gamine parce que là il va
où avec la gamine à l'époque on avait
parlé d'une Clio qu'il était monté dans
une Clio et qui sauvait avec une Clio il
faisait quoi s'il arrivait à monter dans
dans la CL avec la gamine ils allaient
où avec cette gamine on la ryait plus la
pete vous en train de me dire 6 mois
c'est bien 8 mois tant mieux après il va
ressortir et ces mecsl il on comme dit
Cyril ils ont rien à faire avec nous en
société ils ont choisi leur vie il a
choisi sa vie regardez ce qu'il fait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait 8 mois et après il
va s'en prendre un enfant de nous public
qui nous regarde là et on va dire mais
on savait souvenez-vous c'est le mec à
Bordeaux qui a fait ça tu es capable de
faire ça tu as plus rien à faire avec
nous prenez-le comme vous voulez mais
tuas plus rien très très grave ce qu'il
a fait mais je pense que c'est le leut
fa ex la fille il veut pas d'argent il
veut pas de portable il veut la petite
fille Bou pas éliminé de la société lui
alors éliminé de la société ça veut dire
quoi vous le condamnez à perpétuité oui
oui non pas pour ça on peut pas il y a
une gradation les réquésitions du
parquet é parle pas réquition du parquet
je te parle de ce que tu penses toi bah
j'aurais requis comme le parquet je
pense que c'est déjà honnêtement un an
avec de ans
exurc an à injonction de soins
éloignement arrête un peu ave injonction
de soin sa très bien que ça va rien
faire du tout oui ça Jean-Michel Gill le
mettre définitivement derrière les
barreaux c'est sauver quelqu'un je suis
désolé tu vas sauver quelqu'un quand il
va sortir je te mets un billet qu'il va
recommencer et toi en disant bravo la
justice tu te contentes une fois de plus
du peu et je suis désolé de te dire une
fois de plus que dans aucun autre pays
il aurait pris un an comme ça il tu V au
ÉtatsUnis auatunis aurait fait 10 ans de
prison prison minimum comme il a joué
l'aspect de la psychiatrie je suis fou
je suis fou comme beaucoup de personne
s'amuse à jouer à ça avec la justice et
tu le sais gquêteez pour ça là on s'en
réjouit a 6 mois Pr parce que on a
failli passer à côté qui reste
complètement dehors au lieu de se dire
finalement il est pas il est pas si fou
on il a été condamné 15 fois avant on va
pas le laisser partir au bout de 6 mois
cette fois-ci on va essayer lui de le
bloquer compte quand même que tu tu as
dit c'est un miracle qu' qu'il était en
prison non mais c'est ça c'est qu'on se
réjouit de de l'avir dans 6 mois de
refaire vous rendez compte jeter comme
ça une femme âgée par terre prendre la
gamine en plus on s'est pas demandé il
est rentré dans une Clio il avait donc
des complices enfin voyez donc et en
plus on est peut-être à la frontière
entre la psychiatrie et la justice moi
je serais plus rassuré de le voir
enfermer à vie dans un hôpital
psychiatrique parce que la suite du truc
quand on l'a retrouvé en caleçon de bain
et tout ça c'est quand même quelqu'un
qui n quelquun il y a quelqu'un qui vous
demande gillvert destien si la victime
de la tentative d'enlèvement était
quelqu'un de votre famille est-ce que
vous diriez que 2 ans de prison c'est
suffisant pour le coupable dirait oui
Cyril là on si on parle de la dictature
de l'émotion je sais honnêtement je sais
pas comment je réagiraiis je vous
l'avoue très honnêtement je sais pas
comment je réagirait après si on prend
un peu de recul oui qu'il a été jugé
c'est déjà un gros progrès il y a
expertise longue mais oui mais à chaque
fois ici on dit on B il y a plus de
psychiatre là il y a une expertise très
longue qui a permis qu'il soit jugé
c'est une avancée une toute petite
avancée mais une avancée donc je réponds
pas directement à votre question cyil
parce que j'avoue que moi aussi sous la
dictature de l'émotion je sais pas ce
que je serais capable de faire voilà
c'est une avancée ça ça vaut 6 mois de
prison
quoicore on a eu de la chance c'est 2
ans c'est pas 6 mois attends on va se
donner rendez-vous dans 6 mois tu verras
qu'il est use les remise de peine
automatiqu qui sont une catastrophe et
comme dit Radouan il va se tenir
évidemment bien en prison parce qu'il
peut pas jeter des petites filles par
terre en prison donc il
vabér donc il est pas si responsable que
ça du coup la culture de la délinquence
on dit Gil est-ce que vous répondez à ça
mais pas du tout je suis d'une fermeté
terrible je dis mais Cyril je me réjouis
qu'enfin un gars puisse être jugé Daniel
elle dit mais oui mais je réponds Daniel
elle dit on l'enferme à vie dans un
hôpital psychiatrique ça n'existe plus
il sera pas en ferm ave il sortira il
sera pas contrôlé là il est sous les
barreaux j'espère que les soins parce
que bar derrière les barreaux
excusez-moi j'espère que les soins parce
que je cends la psychiatrie pourront
marcher voilà c'est pas que j'ai foi en
l'humanité c'est que ce qu'il a fait est
horrible et qu' soit condamné moi je
trouve que c'est une avancée voilà je
vous répond sincèrement franchement Gill
je te trouve extrêmement balaise pour ne
pas être dans la dictature de l'émotion
depuis 4 ans depuis 5 ans on voit tous
les soirs ici des faits d'hiver
hallucinants avec des G multiondamn
récidivistes avec des dossiers hyper
longs avec des psychiatres qui
finalement décident de dire qu'ils sont
irresponsables mais moi en fait on tane
les policiers en France il y a l'IGPN
qui les met sous pression moi je
voudrais que excusez-moi moi je voudrais
que la psychiatrie rende des comptes je
voudrais que les juges rend des compes
non mais je voudrais qu' que la justice
rend des compte en fait moi en tant que
citoyenne je je je trouve que malgré
tout la justice n'est jamais au
rendez-vous je la trouve extrêmement
laxiste pas dire jamais je la trouve
très tu B les soiss laisse les finir là
laiss finir il travaille peut-être dans
des conditions très difficiles n'empêche
que nous ici tous les soirs on commente
des faits divers où la justice n'est pas
au rendez-vous je suis désolée elle est
pas au rendez-vous elle donne des
jugements 2 ans 3 ans après c'est j ça
va jamais dans le bon sens on a toujours
l'impressionune sorte d'impunité ou de
laxisme donc malgré tout moi je je vous
trouve très fort de pas dans la